m
le premier marché demande pays s'est
déroulée ce dimanche 3 janvier au jardin
de l'état
une opération mise en place par l'arpp
eiffel et le conseil départemental sept
producteurs locaux se sont rassemblés en
ce premier week-end de l'année pour
proposer des mangas petit prix mais
aussi faire découvrir au public les
différentes variétés produites à la
réunion
le but de cette journée dont on a décidé
avec le conseil général une autre
association l'arop-fl avec les plusieurs
coopératives donc de faire une vente
demande au jardin de l'état
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ça correspond à
notre pic de production on puisse le
premier week-end du mois où on ne
saurait les bazardiers soit un peu en
vacances nous prévenu c'est l'occasion
de faire découvrir les mangues au jardin
et à et puis on a choisi le conseil
général parce que c'est c'est la
collectivité qui aide les habitudes
le public va pouvoir redécouvrir la
mangue faisait la demande américaine et
une découverte de variété il veut des
prix la mouna fettou pratiquement à 2
euros le kilo les jolis noms quand on
sait qu'aujourd'hui en bon fédéraux donc
là on a fait vraiment écrit attac
attractif qu'on fait découvrir justement
cette annonce ils étaient des centaines
à s'être donné rendez-vous dans les
allées du jardin de l'état
l'occasion de goûter de nouvelles
saveurs mais surtout de faire le plein
de mangue grâce aux prix très attractifs
un marché qui semble avoir conquis les
passants repartis les mains chargées de
fruits
on est venu c'est des membres parce que
j'adore les membres d'abord les membres
ici il ya tout un choix et qu'ils sont
moins chers que si dans des cités vente
et traditionnels jeux directement du
producteur et encourager le producteur
je sais que rarement et cartons carton
plein dans ce que je fais aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est vraiment intéressant
on adore le monde et puis c'est un
produit local qui est très très apprécié
ben là aujourd'hui on peut l'acheter
suffisamment très très intéressant
à renouveler l'opération un succès
auquel ne s'attendaient pas les sept
producteurs venus sur le marché avec six
tonnes de mangues
deux heures après l'ouverture un
réapprovisionnement est déjà nécessaire
aujourd'hui ça a beaucoup bougé je
pensais que le matin fallait être un
petit peu doucement mais finalement ça
il y avait beaucoup de monde y avait du
monde m'ont d'ailleurs on est en rupture
m'attendais pas du tout à ça on est
arrivé à peu près avec une demi-tonne de
mangue et là tout est parti c'est un
moyen pour les producteurs dans un
premier temps de se faire connaître et
aussi d'écouler leurs stocks sur le
marché local parce que c'est vrai qu'à
mais aussi de l'exportation
mais l'avantagé de faire goûter aux
clients c'est que les gens ils
redécouvrent dans les manques d'avant
comme la josé et puis l'américaine est
la même depuis la nouveauté des gens
en fait les gens il aurait mangé sûrs ou
l'ange la bombe et comme comme c'est
plein de vitamines donc c'est bon pour
la santé
on va dire les passants eu raison de
faire le plein de man car ce fruit sucré
et juteux incontournable dans
l'alimentation réunionnaise ne sera
produit que sur deux mois cette année